cinco años después de su firma turquía
ratificó el acuerdo climático de parís
uniéndose así a la lucha global contra
el cambio climático pocas semanas antes
de la cumbre cop 26 que se celebrará en
glasgow escocia los legisladores turcos
aprobaron por unanimidad el pacto hemos
dado otro paso importante en el
movimiento de desarrollo verde iniciado
bajo el liderazgo de nuestro presidente
erdogán la propuesta de aprobación del
acuerdo climático de parís fue aceptada
por unanimidad en la asamblea general
del parlamento de turquía casi
doscientas naciones han adoptado el
acuerdo que compromete a los
participantes a mantener el
calentamiento global por debajo de los
dos grados centígrados durante años
ankara se había mostrado reticente al
ratificarlo es haberlo firmado en 2016
argumentando que las naciones del sur
global son responsables de una parte muy
pequeña de las emisiones de carbono
turquía que aparecía como país
industrializado buscaba también ser
reclasificado como país en desarrollo
para evitar objetivos más estrictos en
la reducción de emisiones por ello el
parlamento señaló que será aplicado
siempre que no se perjudique a su
desarrollo económico y social en su
intervención ante la asamblea general de
la onu el presidente de regev tayyip
erdogán pidió mayor responsabilidad a
las naciones ricas
william james jones a diferencia del
pasado esta vez nadie puede permitirse
el lujo de decir que soy poderoso para
no pagar la factura porque el cambio
climático trata tranquilamente a la
humanidad por igual sin importar las
diferencias entre el europeo o el
asiático el americano o el africano el
rico o el pobre
en los últimos meses turquía ha sufrido
una serie de desastres naturales que han
devastado el país desde sequías
inundaciones a los peores incendios
forestales de su historia un impulso
para unirse a la lucha contra la crisis
climática